you let me go
ah
listen everywhere you go
you're leaving puzzle pieces for anyone
who's looking
I played stayed under the radar do I
know you
eugene van winger the barber it's not
your real name though isn't a surfacing
you're restricted the fellow you brought
they say they've spouted some story Lena
Punky's got a real smart hat he's a
serial killer named Francis Allen Visser
mr. Visser is a fine upstanding citizen
I know they had particular lack of
evidence no witnesses no fingerprints no
17 pockets it's a lot to look away from
they kind of loose for a reason no
motives no prints no DNA would even get
him on the candlestick at a library I'm
gonna learn anything who I am what I am
send me for you what are you warned from
I want you to teach me how to kill you
want to be this person
I want to know how you picked up scuse
me what's the trigger what's the thing
hey mister this one not that one you
should wear your suit though
can't be too careful I've gotten
convinced that I'm a killer - I kind of
miss closely telling me everything he's
playing apart just go ran into you boy
last night man look he's not moving
Christian he monitors women hard right
there can be no forgiveness without the
shedding of blood
you